if you take away the opening theory from
both players he is really really special
he knows where the pieces belong he
knows when to attack when to change the
pace when to accelerate things and you
see on his face he knows he is about to
win wesley as well you can tell on his
his body language he is resigned to the
defeat then white's rook will swing
across and target that black king
okay wesley desperately trying to remove
the queens from the board but the white
queen forced all the way back she's
still eyeing up the black king this time
from a different angle yeah and uh
impressive how she moved across the
board and every single turn she kept on
piling the pressure
yeah the winner takes it all in this one
and it's going to be magnus carson
black's king still stuck in the middle
and white's king in the middle as well
still has the right to castle and that's
why
magnus carson is going to take the win
and there we go we have a result ah
there it is the final game and the final
win for magnus carlsen in the 2021
season what a performance it's been by
the world champion to win the tour
overall and to finish it off against his
biggest rival this season with a match
win after only three games against
wesley so